let's be frank about this next award it
means more to us in the motion picture
business than it does to those of you in
the dental floss manufacturing game I'm
talking about the Irving G Thalberg
Memorial Award and when it is given it's
given to a man whose pictures have stood
out as milestones over the years the
last picture maker to win the Thalberg
award is the genius who will present
another this year his movie milestones
include I want to live West Side Story
and the sound of music with more yet to
come
mr. Robert Wise
tonight's recipient of the Thalberg
award is a picture maker of such
impressive credentials he is long
overdue in formal recognition from his
fellows in the Academy I deem it a
personal privilege to acknowledge what
theatre audiences have recognized for a
third of the century when you examined
the list of his films you were jolted by
the Legion of absolutely top-level
entertainments he has made a record
unball most unmatched by any director
practicing his magic anywhere his first
job in films is in 1920 writing
subtitles to silence in England 1925 he
made his debut as a director and he
still is contributing to a body worked
so distinctive that his name is passed
into the language the name of course is
Alfred Hitchcock from his unforgettable
The Lady Vanishes through Rebecca
lifeboat spellbound rear-window
psycho his briefly titled masterpieces
of suspense adventure and humor have
endeared him to film buffs as certainly
as his own fate presence on the small
screen have endeared him to television
audiences ladies and gentlemen the
familiar figure of Alfred Hitchcock
Thank You Angie
Oh